the greatest innovations in human
history from the wheel to the iPhone all
had one thing in common
great user design as innovations
migrated from the physical world to the
digital the interactions between users
and products need to be designed to
ensure a great user experience in
Udacity's brand new user experience
designer nanodegree program you'll learn
UX fundamentals and how to conduct
design research and when you finish
you'll be adept at journeying from
concept to low fidelity prototypes and
from prototypes to high fidelity UX
designs for the capstone project you'll
build a case study that can be
incorporated into a UX design portfolio
the projects will give you real-world UX
design experience and you'll be able to
use them to showcase your skills to
prospective employers Udacity is UX
designer nano degree program teaches you
everything from visual design basics to
UX design fundamentals to how to convert
lo-fi sketches into hi-fi interactive
designs using figma that are ready for
engineering handoff UX design is
everywhere in the smartphone in your
pocket - the interactive menus on
television shape how humans interact
with our world's greatest products
enroll in Udacity user experience
designer nano degree programs today
you